[Music]
today we will look at the mcu timeline
after avengers end game
so the events of end game began in
mid-2018 and then after thanos death it
jumps to five years later putting them
in the year 2023 on a connecting note
berry brand reveals in spider-man far
from home that the snap individuals were
brought back as she said eight months
ago and this was spoken on the final day
of school before summer in late june
2024
therefore this would put the blip in
october 2023
then on the ending scenes of end game we
see a full moon rises over wakanda
approximately 11 days after hulk snap on
the night of october 28 2023 making the
battle for earth on october 17 2023 so
subscribe if you haven't already and now
let's get on with this timeline
5th till 17th october 2023 the events of
endgame thanos is defeated iron man
sacrifices himself and a blip happens
due to hulk's snap
returning everyone lost an infinity war
back to life
27th october 2023 peter parker returns
to school and midtown school of science
and technology restarts its academic
year making their credits from 2018
onwards invalid
28 october 2023 wakanda celebrates the
victory over thanos and the return of
the people wiped out during the infinity
stone saga
30th october 2023 thor crowns valkyrie
as the new ruler of the asgardians as he
goes along with the guardians of the
galaxy to new adventures in outer space
31st october 2023 wonder goes to sword
headquarters demanding to see the
vision's body hayward then shows maximum
of vision's deconstructed body being
worked on upsetting maximus that she
couldn't sense vision's presence
5th november 2023 wander uses chaos
magic to create a hex around west view
and control its population maximus
powers create a new version of vision
and they start a new tv life in west
view
10th november 2023 wander defeats agatha
harkness and frees the people of
westview from her chaos magic then white
vision gets all his memories from the
hex vision causing him to leave abruptly
early 2024 valentina lies to elena about
hawkeye being the cause of natasha's
death
thereby motivating elena to search for
clint barton and swearing to kill him
late march 2024 attack on changchi by
ten rings operatives led by razorfist to
find shangti and take his eye of the
dragon thereby causing the start of the
events of shangti and the legend of the
ten rings
early april 2024 shanxi travels to
tallow and with the help of the people
there alongside the great protector he
manages to kill the dweller in darkness
by using the 10 rings
17th april 2024 sam wilson gives up
captain america's shield to the
smithsonian museum declining the chance
to become the new captain america
19th april 2024 john walker a soldier is
named as a new captain america after the
turn down by sam wilson the falcon
7 may 2024 john walker the new captain
america injects himself with a newly
discovered super soldier serum and
becomes a super soldier greatly
augmenting his strength and defeats and
kills one of the flag smashers brutally
in public
18 may 2024 sam wilson bucky barnes
saves the grc the global repatriation
council from the flag smashers who
attempted to kidnap them and use them
for ransom and then sam becomes the new
captain america
20th june 2024 talos and sauren two
skrulls that were trapped on earth
disguised as nick fury and maria hill
arrive in extend go mexico in response
to a recent report of a cyclone with a
face thus starting the elemental attacks
that were secretly done by mysterio
quentin beck
20th june till the 2nd of july 2024 the
events of spider-man far from home
whereby the elementals attacked earth
but were later on revealed to be a ploy
of mysterio quentin back
4th of july 2024 after receiving talis's
message about mysterio and spider-man
nick fury gets up from his augmented
reality beach vacation room and calls
out that they have work to do looking
out at the skrull crew manning a very
large spaceship
10th july 2024
j jonah jameson reveals to the world
that spider-man killed mysterio
and that the identity of the friendly
neighborhood hero is peter parker
between july and october 2024 events of
the eternals whereby the deviants have
been awakened again from under the eyes
and also the celestial tiemouth's
emergence is taking place
middle to late november 2024 peter
parker requests doctor strange to help
him with the fact that everyone knows
that he is spider-man and it's making
his life and his friend's life not that
easy strange offers a spell to erase
most people's memories but due to the
tampering by peter parker people who
know spider-man are dragging from other
universes to the mcu
late november 2024 the battle at
alexander hamilton bridge was the
opening confrontation between spider-man
dr octopus and the green goblin
following doctor strange's botched runes
of cough call ritual which was the
tampering done by peter parker
19th december 2024 starting of the
events of hawkeye when kate bishop
interferes in the robbery of the black
auction market and her adorning the
costume of ronin causing a chain
reaction of the russian mob hunting her
for revenge
24th december 2024 the ending of the
events of hawkeye culminating in the
battle of the rock fellow center where
elena and clint makes peace and she gets
the truth about natasha's sacrifice also
kate bishop defeats the kingpin
early 2025 following the tampering of
the spells of doctor strange in norway
home we now come to the events of doctor
strange multiverse of madness where
wander and strange takes on new threats
from alternate universes we don't know
yet the sequence of events but we do
know that it will happen a short while
after no way home
2050 a rock scott mall located in haven
hills alabama is wiped out by a
hurricane despite relief efforts the
time variants authority classifies this
as a class 10 apocalyptic event this
coincides with the bombing of the sacred
timeline
2027 loki escapes with sylvie to the
moon of lamentus 1 which is said to be
destroyed when a neighboring planet is
on course to crash with it that will
result in the deaths of the lamentings
we now come to the end of time we now
reach the void a place used by the time
various authority to send anyone that is
pruned inhabitants here do not age
because let's face it it's the void
being at the end of time and time
doesn't have effect on it this is also
the location of the citadel at the end
of time where he who remains resides
there awaiting loki
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well to be a
part of the mind cue family but most of
all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos right here on this
channel till the next one take care fam
you